[Applause]
red is my favorite color to wear you're
wearing my favorite color to wear it's
nice to see you i think you are
hilarious you are so talented so gifted
have you met bonnie before no y'all
never met before hello okay you look
gorgeous you look gorgeous thank you um
that was hilarious i loved the lost city
we're going to get to it that was so
funny i love the movie but your parents
were both educators right my mom was a
teacher yeah so growing up my mom was a
kindergarten teacher oh i love that my
mom was first grade yeah yeah yeah like
they're learning to read and yeah that
was stuff was it hard having parents for
well
education's everything yeah so it's
thank you yes but like as a kid as an
adult we know that but as a kid i was
always like i've got it yeah like with
my homework yeah and then like you get
home and you have like the workbook
yep and your mom enforces summer school
yeah oh my god yeah oh my god i never i
never stayed in school for more than
like two or three years because it
wasn't good enough like it was like oh
my god you're going to another school
and another school so then college i was
like whoa
i'm in one place
what a place oh my gosh you moved around
quite a bit yeah that's i moved around a
bit i feel like it kind of made me very
outgoing do you feel like it did that
adaptability is key yeah and then i feel
like
you got to understand who you were like
i felt older like i was more mature
because you had to learn like
what you're good at because you needed a
gimmick right you had to like impress
the new kids with something i went with
humor yes i went with humor humor and i
was like i could do a little a little
bit that i was like okay that combo yeah
get the kids that's why yeah i'd just
laugh at me before anyone else could i
was like i was very defensive with my
insecurity um did you move around ever
when you were a kid or did you stay at
one point we went from california to new
york if my dad had another broadway show
so we were used to going back and forth
oh wow right now i didn't get a tan so i
like these
[Laughter]
um so congrats on the new movie so the
lost city it's so funny y'all we got
slow clap that's why i call him today um
so who tell everybody who you play in it
uh so i play beth and beth is the
publicist best friend stylist all the
things into one to loretta who is sandra
bullock's character and basically it's
like loosely based off of romancing the
stone that's what yeah it was like those
like
yeah it's in there and so i always say
i'm the danny devito character
so basically uh she uh i like forced her
to do this book because she's recently
you know had her husband's past and
she's a little depressed and i'm like
listen like you're really talented but
this is going to be the thing to get you
out of it like on the friends side of
thing and the business side of things
i'm like i need to make money so
you need to get out there
and so she writes this book her husband
was an archaeologist and so she writes
something in the book that leads it to
believe that like
i don't know there's buried treasure and
so then daniel radcliffe aka harry
potter yeah plays the most amazing
villain ever amazing and i felt like
when we were like he might be a little
psycho he's so good at it this is what i
think i think he was doing a good job as
being all sweet and nice as harry potter
and all that stuff was built up that was
the actual that's the real guy he's like
i'm here it's it's so funny i think it's
it's different than like jewel of the
nile romancing those things but it's
just in that vein and i don't feel like
people are making those kind of movies
anymore and they're i love those yeah
you're getting like indiana jones yes
you're getting all of it all the stuff
and i think that was the biggest thing
that surprised us we did not know how
much action it was going to be we
thought it was going to be like cgi but
we just so happened to be filling in d r
and no yeah it was
we
and no
no no because i heard that daniel he was
here recently and he said that you know
he's in all these suits like
in the dominican republic and it's
so hot yeah and he like literally was
like we're gonna have to make a change
like y'all were sweating to death yeah
well because you know you're thinking at
least i was i was like i want to look
amazing i want to be giving the people
looks on looks on looks laughs
and then you get out there and you're
like um
i should have just wore a sundress
because you have like full on you're
covered i had a three-piece suit oh ouch
three-piece suit
so he was complaining you had a suit too
yeah and then i had a corset
in a suit
i'm so glad i was born now and not and
yeah because like elastic i would not
laugh
i'm into yoga pants that i've never done
yoga in
that's what i live in with my mom bun
[Music]
you